we are back with the one and only
bridgette everett yes
it is your story give it to us now
yes okay
distractify reports the judges podcast
recently had a listener right in about
an issue with her boyfriend
she slept over at his house for the
first time and discovered
he sleeps in a nest
now there's no mattress just a nest of
his clothes the and the girlfriend tried
to go with it but she ended up sleeping
on the couch yeah she did they got in a
big fight afterwards and he says he
won't part with the nest and she says
well that might be a little bit of a
deal breaker
drew
what's the weirdest place that you've
fallen asleep
i have a really weird thing i won't
sleep next to my friends i just won't do
it i'm too uncomfortable uh so i've like
slept on a pool table or like in a
bathtub
i just i'm like it's too intimate and
weird if if i'm intimate with someone
then yeah great but like i don't know
why i just have
i will not share a bed with my friends
interesting okay what would what would
you think if you got to a guy's house
and he had a nest of clothing well i
like to try new things
and
you know i like to never say no to
what's possible
as a young rudy rudiger would point out
until you really put your full heart in
it you're not going to know how to win
this is a no-go for ross matthews
if you sleep in a nest of your dirty
clothes that's a mattress-sized red flag
right i mean what is next are you
you're not making good choices in your
life i i this is just it's such a deal
breaker for me i i mean i was making a
joke about the places i've slept to
avoid sleeping with my friends and in a
bed but this is nuts but you know what i
would do i don't know if you guys
remember the movie rudy yeah there's a
scene
where the where the captain goes into
the into uh the the coaches office and
he has his jersey and he puts it on the
desk and he says i'd like rudy to dress
in my place and coach says well
you know you're the captain and the
all-american i think you should act like
and he said i believe i am and then they
come in and it's one jersey on another
jersey on another jersey the next thing
you know there's a nests of jerseys
[Applause]
jerseys we're going to cuddle up and
typically
all right next up we'd love to turn this
desk into a test lab and try out all the
latest and greatest products on the
market this is drew's reviews
and today we've got a pic sent in by
me i just saw this and i thought you
know what
i have to have this because oh
that's right it's an extendable fork see
we all have plates up here here
so if you don't mind kindly you know you
just want to say to someone do you like
that clock on the wall
and then
you know just
but that's my wiener
[Applause]
hey
drew look over there look over there
let's get her nuggets
linda's just happy
so happy and when you're done with the
meal you got yourself a little back
scratcher too isn't that nice
oh no i made a mess on your plate sorry
oh my god
are you guys in i'm i'm all right
how many stars
how many stars would you give it
bridgette out of five
i'm giving this a five out of five
similar
to the time that rudy got in on that
last play in the game
and they just needed to go five yards
attack stack that quarterback and he did
it
this is a five out of five for me i love
it rothy
five out of five for the same reason
i'm giving it a five out of five because
i anticipated the joy it would give me
and it's giving it to me so far
richard everett i love you you have been
honestly my favorite for so long and
this
um new project of yours i think just
continues to show all of your capacities
and
magnanimous talents you really are
everything and i'm so excited for this
project somebody somewhere
is on sunday nights at 10 30 on hbo and
hbo max it is phenomenal and so are you
[Music]
you